do 15 names for the Hall of Fame oh I
saw that recently yeah it just came out
right do you have that can you find that
because you know I always champion the
offensive lineman and you know there's a
name that I there's a couple of names
that I bring up and I think both are on
the final 15 if you can check that for
me McLovin Todd do you have it look at
it right now I see Troy Polamalu Reggie
Wayne John Lynch Steve Atwater Boselli
Isaac Bruce Leroy Butler Torry Holt
Steve Hutchinson Allen Faneca Edgerrin
James hmm Sam Mills Richard Seymour Zach
Thomas Bryant young because man you got
a couple of linemen on there you know
Faneca might get in there before tony
Boselli has been nominated and you know
i just know the eye test when I saw Miss
Ellie play he was special Jimbo covert
to me when the Chicago Bears was special
just different athletic you know not big
plotting lineman Steve Hutchinson's he
was great too but I always tried to
champion the offensive linemen because
you know you're trying to figure out
like what what stats do you have you
know how many sacks did you give up or
how many holding penalties did you have
that's that's about it or how many
thousand yard rushers did you have
behind you but Jimbo covert Tony Bocelli
I hope they get that opportunity yeah
Polly Torry Holt wide receiver Isaac
Bruce wide receiver mostly with the Rams
with their hay days they might cancel
each other out I don't know you almost
wish that that Rams team could go in as
a group like a band like it's a Hall of
Fame if you could almost do a display on
the greatest one of the great often
sneeze all-time and put the entire Rams
offense in as some type of group award I
know they don't do that
but it feels like a slight not to have
them in there some have they changed the
process McLovin with the Hall of Fame
but is there some like big class this
year that everybody's gonna get it
remember we tagged leepu's gonna get in
this year because of some extra class
I'll find out you know like more guys
who miss it the first time we're gonna
get a shot I don't know why no the
process of telling you how you got in
the Hall of Fame always that's changed I
thought was a knock on the door from
that big guy who runs
but but wide so they have everybody in a
room I believe and that I just think
it's unfair it's painful that you go
they knock on the door and then they say
you're in and you're in and you're in
you're in and rest of you aren't like
why does it have to be almost
humiliating if you don't make it a
little I can't imagine what that would
be like if you don't get the call you
don't get a knock on the door and you're
just sitting there and then all of a
sudden you dispersed and everybody's
like guys and then they walk right out
right onto the stage I think the NFL
Network and rich eyes and interviews him
yeah pulling the hall-of-fame board
recently passed a resolution that
suspended the Hall of Fame's selection
committee bylaws for the class of 22 20
20 20 just this summer the measure is
intended to honor the NFL's centennial
celebration through a special centennial
class that would comprise of 20 members
in 2025 modern era players and 10 senior
players three contributors and two
coaches it's like they're gonna do a one
time correction this summer so that it's
gonna be the biggest class by far in
history there will be 20 people to
summer mandatory yes hunt our friend
Rich Eisen is missing as he always is
and I wanted to help us out with this
rich thanks for joining us are they
still doing that painful process of how
they inform these guys that they're in
or not well what used to be was totally
unorganized where players they knew they
were finalists but they didn't have a
place to be like literally the year
Warren moon was getting in he would be
driving around the circumference of the
city that of the Super Bowl and she knew
he had a shot to get in and he told me
that he was either gonna head to the
convention center where he heard his
name called or head to the airport so
now they have like a luncheon for
finalists and they sit in a hotel room
with their loved ones and wait for a
knock on the door that either comes or
doesn't that might be worse rich telling
me some guys wouldn't even like Harry
Carson didn't make it so many times you
remember you told me
come out of consideration the year he
got in he said screw it I'm not even
going to be at the Superbowl
I'm flying to Hawaii he landed at
baggage claim turned on his phone is
like you have any messages and he turned
around and went back and he's an all
thing now it's actually I told him last
year even realize he's now been an all
of Fame longer than he got it wait you
know but but this year because it's a
class of 2020 they're gonna happen
they're gonna have a special group a
blue-ribbon panel of experts vote on
people that aren't in the the class that
you just mentioned the group that you
just mentioned the normal if you will
conventional group where they're going
to I don't know the exact number like
you know Veterans Committee people and
three coaches two contributors I might
be screwing up the numbers but it's
going to create a class of twenty four
twenty twenty I just don't know
personally this is more personal in a
way than for professional and personal
together I think they might have like
two different induction ceremonies this
weekend one that's been conventional one
and the one that for the other class
that's going to make it a bigger class
for 2020 is there are they told how long
they can go you know they're yeah oh
yeah but nobody listens you stood it
used to be it used to be the worst
speeches when you're sitting there you'd
hold your breath is when somebody got
sup goes out there and says I have no
notes now it's all written it's all in a
prompter and it goes on absolutely
forever they used to have they used it
you know the as you remember they they
used to have the presenters give
speeches - I know but that ended the
year where Steve Young's dad grit and
wound up speaking longer than Steve did
he Jordan asked list of all the people
who slided his son his life and went
right down one by one and then later on
after they said that you need to type up
your your speeches and speak if you're a
presenter Ted Katrina went on forever
when you're introducing Bruce Smith but
the worst one for me was that was the
year I was the actual emcee of the event
because Furman excuse about Wilson and
they said you can't emcee and be a
presenter so emceed the event and that's
when bullet Bob Hayes went in and that's
also when Derrick Thomas went in and the
rule was the presenter could only speak
for five minutes because they were you
know introducing somebody who was
deceased
so both Bob Hayes was introduced by
Roger Staubach the Navy man went five
minutes on the dot and then Carl
Peterson the longtime GM of Kansas City
introduced Derrick Thomas with a quarter
of a 20-minute speech that went on so
long I was able to get up from the stage
to go backstage to ask all what I should
do
at which point as I he'll turn to go
back on the stage
I found Roger Staubach saying hey rich I
thought you're supposed to only speak
for five minutes and he's going on at
which point the six-year-old hey thanks
for calling in all right
Rich Eisen for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]